en france 24 también hablamos de
economía y para ello está daniela
blandón ramírez en el estudio conmigo
daniela vamos hablando primero que de
perú donde el gobierno rechazó una
polémica sobre el ponerle topes a las
tasas de interés o la marina buenas
noches primero que le parece que hacemos
un contexto mire el 30 de diciembre
pasado el congreso aprobó una ley que
impone la llamada tasa de usura este es
un límite que varios países como por
ejemplo colombia establecen
periódicamente a las tasas de interés
que cobran las entidades financieras la
norma también prohíbe que estas
entidades del des cobren a los clientes
cuando incumplan o se atrasen en sus
pagos más allá de los intereses también
elimina otros cobros como los de
membresía o afiliación en los bancos o
ciertas comisiones por retiro en cajeros
automáticos pero el gobierno decidió
rechazar la dice que puede inhibir la
inclusión financiera y que además es
inconstitucional y por eso prefiere que
siga la libre competencia el presidente
la objeto diciendo que afectaría el
proceso d
bancaria y vamos al norte ahora del
continente de las cifras más recientes
dan una luz de esperanza sobre la
recuperación del empleo en eeuu
el informe mensual de moody's analytics
dice que oeste muestra más bien cuántos
empleos se crearon en el sector privado
mensualmente y para enero
particularmente fueron 174 mil casi
cuatro veces más de los 49 mil que se
esperaban y en diciembre habían caído en
78 mil estas contrataciones pues el
análisis de se conoce justo en medio de
las negociaciones entre el presidente
joe biden para un paquete de estímulos
de 19 millones de dólares pero del que
los republicanos ofrecen apenas 600 mil
millones de dólares
of the nation with winter the bigger
fortín ellos están de acuerdo sobre la
necesidad de actuar con rapidez para
garantizar que obtengamos pagos directos
de 1400 dólares a los estadounidenses de
clase media y trabajadora lo antes
posible debemos tomar medidas para
lograrlo
y hablamos ahora de india porque la
prolongada protesta de agricultores tuvo
una nueva jornada violenta si unos 200
manifestantes terminaron agrediéndose
con policías que trataban de dispersar
una marcha hacia el edificio del
parlamento en nueva delhi los campesinos
indios llevan más de dos meses exigiendo
que se les se derogue una reciente forma
agrícola que eliminaría el actual
sistema de precios establecidos por el
gobierno para que negocien directamente
con sus clientes pero ellos piensan que
quienes al final se van a terminar
beneficiando son las grandes
corporaciones la protesta ha alcanzado
tal magnitud marina que ya suma apoyo de
occidente la famosa cantante rihanna y
la activista ambiental grieta tamberg
entre otros se solidarizaron en redes
con la etiqueta farmers protesta
llevando el mensaje a más de 100
millones de seguidores y el gobierno de
mexico entró en una disputa con una
prestigiosa casa de subastas porque mire
es la casa de subastas christie's que
próximamente va a ofrecer en parís una
larga lista de objetos
hasta ahí todo muy bien algunos de ellos
están valorados hasta en un millón de
dólares para escuchemos cuál es el
problema
en ella concretamente se están
ofreciendo para subastar el 9 de febrero
se habla de 33 bienes que se vinculan a
culturas o civilizaciones que
florecieron en méjico de esas 33 piezas
hemos ya determinado que 3 son falsas
pues entre estos objetos hay una máscara
que dataría del 450 antes de cristo- el
gobierno dice que estos objetos son
sagrados y parte de su patrimonio por lo
que no se deben vender por eso está
tratando de recuperarlos por canales
diplomáticos inclusive presentó una
denuncia en la fiscalía general la casa
de subastas dice por su parte que no
tiene evidencia de que estos objetos
hayan sido saqueados o robados y que va
a seguir con la venta nos veremos en qué
termina esta disputa vamos con indicador
de la jornada o streeter cerró mixto en
una jornada impulsada por los buenos
resultados financieros de grandes
tecnológicas como la matriz de google y
amazon en europa allí lideró la bolsa
italiana que subió más del 2% para
recibir con mucho agrado al economista
mario draghi en él
y vamos con la cifra del día los 15 mil
millones de dólares en conjunto que
ganaron las multinacionales nintendo y
sony entre abril y diciembre de 2020
casi el doble frente al año anterior eso
se dio por el repunte de las ventas de
consolas de juegos del switch y
playstation 5 respectivamente durante la
pandemia pues gracias de daniela por la
información económica de ustedes gracias
hay más en france 24 punto com
[Música]